[Music]
for most of us jumping rope may seem
like a simple childhood pastime but for
this woman it's a way of life my name is
tori boggs and i'm a professional jump
roper for more than 20 years she's been
pushing the boundaries of jump rope and
elevating her craft to unthinkable
levels my favorite moment is when i pull
out my rope do something absolutely
crazy and see how people's minds are
[Music]
blown so at what point did you realize
that you were pretty good at this yeah i
was not good at jump rope when i first
started
those days didn't last long by the age
of 13 she was the grand world champion
one of her signature events is a power
skill called triple unders a triple
under is where you jump up and the rope
makes three revolutions around your body
and you land and it's the only event in
our sport where you're going as long as
you possibly can so jumpers are either
going until they're fatigued or they
make a mistake it's definitely a really
brutal event and requires a lot of power
and endurance
doing a single triple under can be
extremely hard but landing hundreds and
hundreds of triples in a row well
there's only a handful of people on the
planet who can do that
i
tied the world record had to wait two
years to come back to the world
tournament and i tied it again
i had to wait two more years to come
back and i broke the world record but i
wasn't happy with my score because i
knew i could do better two more years
and then finally was able to solidly
break the world record i got 412 triple
unders
tori has since broken her own record and
set a new one
493 consecutive triple unders you're
doing triple unders for six minutes
that's a long time to be doing this
constant jump and going through the burn
of different parts of your body as you
go whether it's starting with your legs
moving to your arms and then you're kind
of losing eyesight a little bit
sometimes
job tori
good job
tori is a 32-time u.s grand national
champion and a five-time all-around
grand world champion she's traveled the
world teaching jump rope skills
performed with cirque du soleil and
appeared on shows like ellen i remember
the very first time i saw jump rope i
was five years old i thought it was the
coolest thing and couldn't stay away
from it there was a lot of struggle
i was always really having to practice
hard there definitely was never a
natural talent or affinity towards using
the rope
tori has also broken the world record
multiple times in an event called three
minute speed where jumpers use a wire
metal rope that moves so fast it can be
hard to see i definitely encourage
people to know how to control the rope
before they move to a wire rope because
it moves so quickly and when you mess up
you feel it i even still am making
mistakes and leaving wire whip marks on
my body sometimes
torrey says she first broke the 3 minute
speed world record when she was just 11
years old not satisfied she spent the
next 10 years perfecting her technique
you're thinking about all these
technique points as you go along and of
course you're tired so as you get more
exhausted you're lowering your feet too
much there's always that balance of like
you don't want to be lifting your leg so
high because that takes so much energy
but you also have to keep them up a
certain distance so that you're keeping
your timing on there's all these little
intricate factors that go to make really
just one jump
come together
at 20 years old she broke the record
again this time with 1010 jumps
averaging a ridiculous 5.61 jumps per
second for three straight minutes and i
remember finishing the event i dropped
my rope and my mom was on the floor with
me and we both just broke down in tears
because
how many years in the making it was to
get this record and my brother ran down
from the stands because he also knew all
of the hours that i've spent in the gym
so this was a really special
for sure world record yeah
[Music]
nobody can agree on where exactly jump
rope started but we know it's been
around since at least the 1600s in
modern times it's gained fame as a
playground activity a fitness craze and
a training tool for boxers but it's also
a global sport with competitors from
more than 50 countries
and tori's been a pioneer pushing new
techniques and inventing new tricks
so i always say that when you learn and
you jump up skill
you can say that you have it after
you've done it five times but to really
know the skill it takes a good 30 times
mic release is where you're letting go
of one handle but the rope is still
moving in a forward direction it looks
like it defies laws of gravity but it's
really simple physics that makes this
skill work it kind of blows everyone's
minds
splits are doing a split with a jump
rope in your hand the tricky part of
this is that you gotta jump out of it or
else it's not a jump rope skill
there's another skill that i'm kind of
known for it's called the bubble the
bubble is where you're jumping up off
the air and then the rope is moving
horizontally around your body
forward kamikaze you're starting in
push-up position and you jump and swing
the rope around you and land back in
push-up position
the back tuck is a back flip with the
jump rope it was really scary when i
first started doing it i was about 10.
now it's an easy skill that i can just
like oh let me go run and do a backflip
with my jump rope
the tj is the most famous of your probe
skills the tj consists of a side swing
to start and then when you cross your
arms the bottom arm is going under one
leg this is called a toad or leg over
cross and then the last part of the
skill is opening your arms and jumping
out of it
the webster is a one footed front flip
the thing with doing any forward front
flips is you're always worried about the
landing once you get around you got to
get back up into the next jump and keep
moving on
one of my favorite skills
is called a jammy
so you get a side swing a leg over
and across out of it
i think it looks pretty cool i actually
named my dog jamie because of that skill
i'm known as like a power dynamic jumper
which is how i strive to move with the
rope
so the idea is that i'm constantly kind
of cutting and changing direction
tori has also invented skills never seen
before she named this one the torminator
it's a back extension roll but i have
one handle under my leg and i'm in a
handstand and then reach up and grab the
rope and pull it under me
while the ability to master individual
skills can take years it's the ability
to seamlessly link tricks where a
jumper's creativity and style really
show
everyone has their own unique way of
doing skills which is also really
special about jump rope that you have
your own style
but the really creative part is how you
choose to combine those skills and how
you choose to move with the rope and
that's really where your own individual
style comes into play
[Music]
in general jump rope is a pretty safe
sport
most of my injuries have come from over
training or because i've tried something
new
which has also happened
i was really confident like i can jump
over this rope it's just a little bit
hotter this time right
but i got it wrapped around my ankle
ended up with second third degree burns
my goal then was i'm gonna immediately
tomorrow reset uh re-soak my rope and do
it again
yeah i think that's also a lesson that
i've learned in jump rope is to face
your fears and if something does go
wrong instead of panic and abort let's
problem solve and figure out how to get
around this
jump rope is really hard and a lot of
times people will pick up a jump rope
and immediately get frustrated but it's
really just because they didn't know how
to properly break it down or even it's
an equipment error they didn't have the
right size jump rope and they just
didn't know the first steps to it i feel
very responsible to help someone have a
good experience with jump rope for the
first time because it truly can open so
many doors in their lives whether they
do want to pursue jump rope competition
and challenge themselves in that way or
they're just working with a rope for
fitness or it's just a child having fun
with a jump rope so that's really a
special part of my jump rope career is
being able to teach other people and
share this activity with them
[Music]
pretty much everything i've learned in
life has been through jump rope or with
a jump rope in my hand at least
no matter what's going on in my life i
could be in the lowest of moments but
when i pick up my jump rope i just have
such a good feeling and it kind of
brings me out of whatever funk i might
be in and that's not to say i don't ever
have fights with my jump rope we've
definitely gone through this
relationship of i hate you i can't
figure anything out nothing's working
but i think ultimately
i love jumprope because it's fun and it
brings me joy and there's nothing i
would rather be doing with my time than
jumping over a rope which sounds so
silly because it's just something so
inexpensive and simple that can bring so
much joy to people
you